[Music]
welcome to our Thanksgiving fan mail
extravaganza your questions for the
entire hour
on this very special edition of the five
so grab those stretch pants and a
drumstick and let's begin all right
first question Instagram question from
Miss cozy if you were a character Greg
on a float in the Thanksgiving Parade
what would you be hmm that's a good
question I guess I would hmm
what's a float I've never been in a
parade I would be I would guess I would
be Snoopy Snoopy yes that's the only
character you know I'd be like going I'm
going I'm trying to think what I haven't
seen would seen a float since I was like
three you don't watch that on Texas well
no parades are terrible for short be a
parade now what Elf on a shelf oh really
something you can look up to the coolest
people about height are usually the
people who are shorter I would be on any
of the floats that have the country
music bands playing okay that's a good
one
wah-wah well you look disgusted I can't
believe that Greg never went to a
Thanksgiving Day Parade well I grew up
on the west coast so we didn't have
parades back then there banned in
California foot footprints actually hurt
the fought the the earth in the in the
bugs crickets in the Southern California
I'm northern Cal we don't have parade
well we we have certain parades but we
don't have we don't but I'm being short
here you can't see behind people so
what's the point I'm not gonna sit on
Jesse's shoulders like yes all right so
I think that I would want my grandkids
to watch me right so their favorites are
like vamp arena do you know this yes and
ladybug okay and then I think Eli my
grandson likes tintin tintin I don't
know
bloats that's the problem what about you
Jeff I don't know if like what is afloat
and what isn't but if there's a
superhero float I got that what am I
like
yeah or like just around likes it have
to be a woman jeez I could be spider-man
yes break out of your boxes that would
make me feel proud okay I wouldn't be a
float I'd be the Grand Marshal of course
that's probably appropriate yeah next
question from Greg's favorite person
Frenchy firecracker on Instagram wants
to know what's your best funny snow
story in New York City Jedediah funniest
in new york city's snow story oh gosh I
mean so many most of them involve me
falling oh I fall a lot I trip over
everything I went oh gosh there was the
time that we went sledding and we all
bought sleds and we were supposed to
erase and I had the sled upside down
they started don't ask how Jeff how do
you do things just happen and everybody
died I lost the race big oh I didn't
make a great snowman all right better
luck with the carrot nose that reminds
me of when the five went sledding in New
Hampshire remember that who could forget
I think Dana won you won no Eric Bolling
won I came in second I'll tell you Greg
loss Northern California's we've
established you don't have snow didn't
have experience no snow no parades no
sleds no fun no wow I don't have a happy
story but last week we had a surprise
snowstorm in New York right and so you
couldn't get you know this is gonna
sound so at least but you couldn't get
any car service to get about I had to
walk from my hotel to Penn Station to
get on the train the Train of course all
the time and I'm falling down like
Jedediah
and then I ran into guessing you know
Joe Biden he was having the same problem
1% Joe the Train story I think it was a
snow day here in the city and I lived in
Long Island and so did O'Reilly and I
called out because I said I couldn't
make it into the city like falling ones
ice is over at the park and you I fell
down and got up before they I'm gonna
but I do remember there's about seven
years ago remember the storms we had
back-to-back and this the snow didn't
melt for like a couple of mono my
goodness I had I was I lived in DC but I
was up here and I ended up staying at
the muse hotel for about six days
because you couldn't get anywhere around
the city and you couldn't get back to DC
so I did a lot of Fox News that is a
great snow thank you thank you all right
my favorite snow story it was a couple
years ago this horrible event called
SantaCon yes is when everybody's people
dress up as Santa Claus they go pub
crawling they get really really wasted
and it was during a storm and I was at a
bar with a buddy who was in a band and
we were in the this great bar on Third
Avenue that had a sign that said no
Santa's from Santa con and all those
drunks and us were outside screaming and
banging on the window and we were on the
inside just drinking laughing our butts
off and all these drunks in us and then
you walk out and they're all like really
annoying people thankfully SantaCon has
pretty much died out it was one of the
it's the worst thing that has happened
in New York City sighs male DeBlasio
that's a movie is it
I think I'm movie but drunk Santa is in
there something called Bad Santa yeah
were you so drunk that you thought you
had imagined it all and it wasn't really
happening it happened the kids watching
Santa is real question from Carla see if
you could be a Thanksgiving side dish
what would you be and why Dana
well I love the cranberries cranberry
sauce cranberry colored sweater
shot into this in a can costs how much
Oh God was already nine something like
that I think so side dish Greg I'd be
gravy cuz then I'd be all over your meat
[Laughter]
you gotta be the stuff and everybody and
it's the only time of the year that I
really eat stuff do you do the stuffing
inside the bird or do you do it on the
side no it comes from inside my mom used
to put it inside and actually now I eat
at other people's homes and most of them
put it inside all right one comes from
the inside of a box I gotta go with you
I'd be the stuffing - it's the best part
I mean this stuffing is the best part
it's like you throw everything together
and it's just bread it's all that stuff
that you're really not supposed if I get
from underneath the sofa cushions when I
make it potatoes
hold the gravy Instagram question from V
ke ke who is your favorite relative and
why one who's your favorite relative
just say it alright wait wait I thought
you were saying that I was your favorite
but I always thought Maxine and you were
related that's right Maxine is not
coming for Thanksgiving if she did know
she subpoena you that's right so my
favorite relative I I guess I you have
to say my wife but she you see my
relative
no unless there's you know well then it
have to be the grandkids drank it all of
them yeah I like my okay not decided
very very tactful go ahead Jed I'm gonna
say my mom because if I don't say her
though mom yeah she'll be really mad but
yeah actually she's like the coolest mom
ever nobody wants to adopt her oh I saw
you
oxen free yeah she's pretty cool so I'm
gonna don't mom I'll be well-fed I won't
anger anyone it's it's a good answer I'm
gonna go with mom - no offense dad and
she texts
she sure does I think I'm going out to
go with the ants aunt patty su and aunt
Donna - and Donna's yeah I think the
ants are gonna have to
okay ants take the day correct well
there's about I think like we have like
13 nieces and nephews all between the
ages of like five and eight it's all
I'll say Bob Bob is about my favorite
one the other ones are smelly kind of
stupid a lot of these nieces and nephews
are really really dumb and you kind of
annoy me but Bob's okay so Cobb wins the
Gutfeld family sweepstakes all right
this one is from Natalie F what's the
biggest Thanksgiving fail you've ever
experienced fail like in the kitchen or
a toast that went really wrong what do
you think Jed well I cooked one year and
everybody knows that's not a good sign
Turkey I'm a terrible chef and everybody
was like you can do it you can do it I
was like I couldn't do it turns out I
couldn't do it turkey was dry that's
like the main course if the turkeys dry
but you know what everybody brought
sides and those were really good so it
worked out all right
all right so I think I think I don't
think it's something I did but I think
it's like eating and whenever anybody
brings a cream dish like creamed
cauliflower cream onions or you know I'm
like what is this is when I was 17 I had
for a year I'd had chronic strep throat
and finally my parents found a doctor a
surgeon who would take my tonsils out
the only day we could get it done was on
the Wednesday the day before
Thanksgiving so I couldn't eat anything
but I could smell at all and Oh Craig I
had to be when we killed Uncle Frank it
was a pact so now that's the name
actually for a plant that we have I've
been raising Bob on my own thank you
very much I actually went to the wrong
house on Thanksgiving I was confused I
went to one aunt it was it the other no
yeah so I was a little late that that's
hilarious
all right did he tell you to get leave
the wrong house
thought I was being dissed all right